bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 78 lactu
sur TVfil 78 le journal de la rédaction
et pour débuter cette semaine la colère
des sages femmes qui prend de l'ampleur
mobilisé depuis 4 mois et demi après
trois manifestations nationales elle
s'agace du retard repris dans la
décision de la ministre concernant leur
futur statut les sages femmes qui
souhaitent toujours obtenir le statut
médical afin de quitter la catégorie des
professions paramédicales ell
préviennent si elles n'obtiennent pas
gain de cause il y aura une crise sans
précédent dans les maternité de France
après les dernières déclarations de la
ministre ce matin elles attendent
maintenant des avancées concrètes
exemple avec quelques sage-femme au
chaînet ça va dans le bon sens c'est une
évidence elle parle elle utilise les
mots en tout cas qui nous font plaisir
de reconnaissance du statut médical de
la profession de stage femme donc c'est
exactement ce qu'on veut maintenant on
attend de savoir ben voilà avec
précision ce qu'elle entend et quel va
être ce nouveau statut pour les
sages-femmes on ose y croire après on on
est très méfiante c'est un un mouvement
qui dure depuis 4 mois et demi mais
comme vous l'avez noté tout à l'heure
c'est un mouvement qui est en cours
depuis 2001 d'ailleurs Marie sol Touren
l'a dit dans l'interview ce matin
qu'elle a accordé à europin donc c'est
quelque chose de très vieux avec des
avancées qui en 12 ans sont inexistantes
concernant le
statut et la ministre marieol Touren qui
devrait donc apporter plus de précision
sur ce nouveau statut des sages-femmes
ce sera dans la journée de demain mardi
ce weekend le Secours populaire de
manilamo accueillait dans ses nouveaux
locaux les bénéficiaires de l'aide
alimentaire de l'association une aide
toujours aussi vitale matériellement
qu'humainement Olivier Manis calco
Patrick Jacques de pour les
images comme Muriel qui vient chercher
ses produits alimentaires ils sont
environ 130 personnes bénéficiaires de
l'aide du Secours populaire à l'antenne
de Manil etamo une aide précieuse pour
la manicoise qui vit aujourd'hui avec
moins de 800 € de revenus par mois et
qui ne peut plus travailler à la suite
de deux embolies pulmonaires voà je suis
contente de venir mais pas pas forcément
pour l'alimentation bon pour
l'alimentation bien sûr
mais l'ambiance et tout franchement là
toutes les toutes les filles tous les
même les messieurs ils sont super sympas
je viens une fois par mois et ça faire
ça va faire 3 ans maintenant guidé par
les services sociaux de la commune de
Manil et amau ce sont aujourd'hui 45
familles qui sont accueilllies par une
quinzaine de bénévoles de l'association
il y a un renouvellement il y a des gens
qui finissent par retrouver du boulot
avoir une vie un peu plus agréable et
qui sont ravis de ne plus venir nous
voir parce que ça veut dire que ça va
mieux et d'autres familles qui arrivent
sur manier et qui ont besoin de notre
aide pour 1 € par personne un colier
alimentaire copieux permet de se
ravitailler une fois par mois
l'association propose aussi des
vêtements et des produits d'hygiène pour
quelques dizaines de
centimes et puis après le Secours
populaire à présent cette information
concernant les restos du cœur la section
ivelinoise a été victime d'un vol un vol
de tractopel un véhicule qui est utilisé
pendant les collectes il devait servir
dans les prochains jours nous sommes en
ligne avec Henry F le responsable
communication des restos dans les
Yvelines bonsoir à vous euh bonsoir
bonsoir pouvez-vous nous repréciser un
peu les les circonstances de de ce vol
c'était au clés sous-bois ça touche la
section villinoise des resto on a un
entrepôt au clés sous-bois et on partage
une cour qui est fermée par une barrière
avec une autre entreprise qui avait un
petit traxopel un tout petit et donc
donc des voleurs sont venus dans la nuit
ont fracturé la barrière ont volé le
tractopen mais pour le transporter il
leur fallait un camion donc ils ont
d'abord pris un premier camion des
restau du cœur qu'ils
ont àîner en essayant de débloquer le
Noman ouvrir le capot et cetera ils ont
pas pu le démarrer et ils on on pris un
deuxième qui là ils ont démarré et ils
ont emmené le tractopel c'est un c'est
un traficque voyez c'est c'était tout
tractopel et donc on a retrouvé le
camion brûlé à Plaisir voilà alors c'est
pas la première fois que les restos sont
victimes de vol ou de vandalisme comment
vous pouvez expliquer ce ce phénomène et
puis surtout comment vous vous réagissez
qui êtes à la tête d'une association qui
vient en aide au plus démunis oui nous
on trouve ça scandaleux quand même si
vous voulez c'est que on essaie d'aider
les plus démunis et défavorisés et on
est victime de de vol ou d'agression
alors je suppose le camion avait bien un
logo resto du cœur quoi dessus mais je
suppose qu'ils avaient pas d'autres
moyens pour transporter et donc c'était
pas nous qui disait c'était le tractopel
mais on a été victime collatéral et ça
va pénaliser fortement vos actions
notamment à la fin de la semaine où une
collecte une collecte est organisée
comment vous allez vous organiser SEM à
la fin de cette semaine on a une
collecte la collecte nationale qui est
le vendredi samedi dimanche on a 40
magasins qui participent sur les
vivelines et pour rapatrier les que on
espère récolter dans 120 130 tonnes pour
être rapatrier ça il nous faut bien
entendu des moyens de transport donc on
va louer un camion et on fait un appel
si quelqu'un veut bien nous prêter ou
nous
donner un camion type trafic vous voyez
où on peut mettre deux trois palettes ça
ça nous aidrait bien voilà afin de
veilleridment au bon déroulement de
cette collecte peut-être pour conclure
un mot justement sur cette collecte elle
est particulièrement
important à ce moment de la de la
campagne d'hiver pour terminer les les
dernières semaines qu'il reste non
seulement elle est importante pour la
campagne d'hiver mais ça va être la
principale ressource pour la campagne
d'été parce que la plupart de nos
centres sont encore ouverts en été
et c'est c'est grâce à cette campagne
qu'on va
pouvoir faire cette campagne d'été qui
va être de mai juin on sera probablement
fermé en juilletaoût et ouvert de
nouveau en septembre octobre sur plus de
la moitié de nos centres merci Henry FAL
d'avoir été en ligne avec nous hein
n'oubliez pas donc de de participer
d'aider les resto avec cette collecte
qui sera organisée en fin de semaine et
puis si vous souhaitez également venir
en aide au resto en en prêtant ce ce
véhicule qui a été volé vandalisé durant
les les derniers jours ça permettra bien
évidemment de veiller au bon déroulement
de l'opération sur le weekend merci donc
à Henry FAL qui était en ligne avec nous
ce soir et on rappelle cette collecte
qui sera organisé dans une quarantaine
d'hypermarché dans le département la fin
de la semaine politique à présent avec
le scrutin municipal ce soir nous nous
penchons sur ces jeunes candidats de
moins de 30 ans la génération Y veut
aussi jouer les premiers rôles plusieurs
têtes de liste sur le terrain yvelinois
depuis ces derniers mois tour
d'horizon ils ont moins de 30 ans au
cœur de la génération Y et sont tête de
liste dans les Yvelines pour ces
prochaines municipales c'est
principalement l'UMP qui a décidé de
miser sur le renouveau de ses candidats
pour tenter de l'emporter dans des
bastions de la gauche attrappe manilé à
mogu ou encore comme ici à La Verrière
c'est ma première expérience en
politique ma première élection je
travaille pour la mairie d'élancour pour
le maire d'élancours donc je connais
bien la gestion d'une ville je suis sans
étiquette j'ai jamais fait partie
d'aucun mouvement politique après j'ai
des valeurs très fortes des
convictions personnelle très présente
être jeune pour un candidat au municipal
à tout ou handicap leurs aînés leur
reproche un manque d'expérience il mise
sur le dynamisme rappelons tout de même
qu'un certain Nicolas Sarkozi
l'emportait sur scène à 28 ans et à
l'UMP justement Aurore berger depuis
maniléamo se verrait bien renouveler cet
exploit même si elle reconnaît la
difficulté des classes politiques à se
renouveler c'est vrai qu'on a du mal
aujourd'hui à renouveler nos élus on a
du mal à renouveler en terme de
génération on a du mal à renouveler
faire appel à la diversité et aussi à
faire appel à la parité et je crois que
pour ma génération ce sera quelque chose
de naturel parce qu'on a toujours vécu
avec des gens issus la diversité avec
des gens plus jeunes avec des gens enfin
des femmes des hommes donc je pense que
c'est plus encore une fois une question
de génération et renouvellement engagé
en politique depuis 2001 tous n'ont en
revanche pas le même rapport avec la
politique si Ladislas scoura a pris sa
carte à l'UMP à 16 ans d'autres comme
Hotman nasrou gardent leur distance pas
encore encarté ils préfèrent se
revendiquer gouliste tout en se disant
non partisan UMP mais aussi FN mise sur
les moins de 30 ans à Plaisir notamment
où Alexandar Nikolic défend les couleurs
du rassemblement bleu marine lui qui a
27 ans a débuté son engagement politique
avec l'extrême gauche en dehors de
l'échiquier politique sans étiquette on
notera aussi à en cours la présence
d'une liste menée par un collectif
Génération solidaire ce manque
d'expérience je pense que ça ne veut pas
dire un manque de compétence c'est bien
au contraire on est en train de
rassembler une équipe qui est compétente
donc que soit dans le domaine budgétaire
comme vous ai dit c'est un domaine
auquel je me connais vraiment beaucoup
le développement économique dans le dans
le domaine social dans le domaine donc
de la solidarité dans le domaine aussi
des travaux publics on essaie de
développer les choses au niveau de
l'éducation donc je pense qu'au niveau
de la compéten que les compétences que
les projets et que les idées et aussi
que la motivation est vraiment là moyen
d'â en France des mè 57 ans selon
l'étude menée par un sociologue en 2012
et reprise dans le quotidien les écho
reste à voir si le scrutin permettra
cette année de faire baisser cette
moyenne dans le reste des Yvelines on
notera que les listes menées par des
jeunes trentenaires sont aussi
nombreuses et du divers droite Grégoire
Leclerc à Rambouillet 31 ans à Vivien
Gasque socialiste de 33 ans à Montini le
Bretonneux il faudra encore patienter
quelques jours voire même quelques
semaines pour connaître le budget 2014
définitif de l'université de versaill
5qutin uneeline une université emploie
un déficit de 5,2 million d'euros selon
un dernier communiqué de l'établissement
ce budget devait être connu au 1er mars
finalement il n'en est rien le rectorat
qui doit statuer nous a fait savoir que
le budget serait dévoilé dans le courant
du mois de mars sans dévoiler pour
autant une date précise un budget
définitif qui devrait donc se composer
en partie d'une avance remboursable
versé par l'État et puis en partie
également un d'économie supplémentaire à
réaliser aujourd'hui tris mars on
retiendra également dans l'actualité
l'installation d'une nouvelle sculpture
de l'artiste cinquantinois Nicolas San
attrape dans le jardin de l'hôtel
d'aglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline donc ce dernier a dévoilé iP6 du
nom du matériau métallique qu'il a
utilisé c'est sa 4e réalisation
installée dans l'agglomération son
atelier est basé à hlencour on l'écoute
au micro de Patrick Jacques de dixmud ça
fait partie d'un processus de travail
avec un territoire avec un lieu une zone
géographique et c'est euh et c'est aussi
un peu la la clé de notre collaboration
de ma collaboration avec le avec le
territoire C des vin avec la GL de
saqutin saqutin de ville par rapport à
l'atelier qui m'était mis à disposition
donc en fait c'est comme si je m' quitté
aujourd'hui des loyers de Monlieu un mot
de sport pour conclure ce journal et du
Fotu les Templiers deslcours pour leur
premier match à domicile confirme la
victoire facile de la semaine dernière
cette fois-ci ils se sont imposés face à
anère sur scène c'était samedi soir le
résumé avec Anthony res et Patrick
Jacques de dixmud en 2014 les Templiers
ferment d'abord la porte de Laurent but
ensuite sur leur série offensive il fut
confiance au jeune chunchelton le
nouveau quatback américain montre tout
son talent réalisant une impressionnante
course face à la défense adverse deux
actions plus tard il trouve son receveur
Anthony Couvin qui crochette son
défenseur avant de filer au touchdown
pour une réception de plus de 45 yards
7-0 ça c'est vraiment très bien passé
bon il faut dire qu'on a donc on a 5 si
receveurs qui sont très très bons TR ou
qure qui sont les meilleurs du du
championnat de France donc on on
facilite un peu l'arrivée du quterbike
lui il est bon il fait ce qu'il faut on
avait les receveurs en face voilà ça
c'est la connexion s'est vite passée il
est venu il est arrivé maintenant il y a
un mois et demi donc tout va bien quoi
au début du second quartemp les
Templiers mènent rapidement 140 mais
leurs affaires se compliquent
brutalement après l'expulsion d'Antony
Couvin pour un coup de casque sur al la
ruelle mais les Molos ne concrétisent
pas leur possession 14-0 à la mi-temps
au retour des vestiaires SH Shelton
impeccable jusque là va remettre les
moloses dans le match par une perte de
balle à quelques mètres de l' but
adverse un turnover qui offre leur
deuxème touchdown au visiteur 147 les
molosses ne parviendront pas à revenir
et verront leurs espoirs douchés par un
dernier touchdown de Christophe Morin et
surtout cette interception de Thib
Conchon score final 217 avec cette deuxè
victoire en autant de journée les
Templiers s'annoncent clairement comme
l'une des équipes à battre de ce début
de
saison pour le reste de l'information
sportive rendez-vous 18h30 19h30 et 23h
chaque lundi sur TVfil le 78 sport
présenté par Antony Resche l'actu
revient demain 18h en direct sur TVfil
vous retrouverez Catherine zulato à la
présentation il sera notamment question
de cette mobilisation des infirmiers les
écoles d'infirmiers qui sont mobilisées
150 à 200 élèves de l'Institut basé à La
Verrière devrait donc défiler demain
nous en parlerons dès 18h d'ici là je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée sur
notre
antenne